Let’s consider a visual metaphor in our discussion about metrics.
We will do this by comparing metrics that exist in a toy shop,
to metrics that exist in operating systems.
For instance, from the perspective of the toy shop manager,
a number of properties of how the workers operate,
how the toy shop is being run, may be relevant.
One example is throughput.
The toy shop manager would want to make sure that this is as high as possible.
Other things that may be important for the toy shop manager include
how long does it take to react to a new order on average?
Or what is the percentage of the workbenches that are used over
a period of time?
There can clearly be many more properties of the toy shop and
how it's run that are relevant to the toy shop manager.
Metrics such as throughput, response time, utilization and
others are also relevant from the operating systems perspective.
For instance, it's important to understand how many processes can be
completed over a period of time on a particular platform.
It's important to know how responsive the system is.
So when we click the mouse, does something happen immediately or
we have to wait some noticeable amount of time?
Does the operating system design lead to a solution that utilizes the CPU,
devices, memory well, or does it leave a lot of unused resources?
So metrics exist in any type of system, and
it's important to have them well-defined when you're trying to
analyze how a system behaves and how it compares to other solutions.